okay now just in case you're still a bit
fuzzy right what's this puppy I'm
translating I'm just lazy to write out
the full sentence okay means X Y
integers and they are positive integers
that's what the question actually says
but you already have time to write it
like that okay so I'm required to prove
this top line okay and the question is
how do I begin
now remember I love Shane just now right
if I'm asked to prove this it's much
easier algebraically for me to prove
that something is positive okay even
though these are meant to the same thing
okay so how can I use that fact here
well here's my a that he's my B okay so
what I'm gonna do is I'll say a minus B
okay so this is my a minus a minus B now
what I want to prove is that that's
greater than zero
okay yep okay I will in a second I will
in a second okay but here's that first
thing I want you to notice right which
is that this is what I'm required to
prove so it can't be the starting point
of my proof okay it can't be the first
line of my proof it should be the last
line of my I don't know where there's
this is true or not or even if I do know
it's true I haven't actually shown it
okay so I can't you know stop here and
then do some algebraic stuff and then
get to some statement which may be true
and then say therefore time less time I
must have in true okay I've said this
lots of times
yes yes but you might as well just write
it properly the first time
okay the reason why is you know you can
do this with all kinds of things right
you can take a you can start with a
false premise and then do legitimate
mathematical things to it you can do all
the dividing by zero is not legitimate
mathematically but squaring both sides
is legit that's fine okay
multiply both sides by zero is also the
gin okay and then saying cool if I ended
it something right then the premise must
have been right right wrong it's not
okay so that's why you can't stop at
this point okay so don't do this instead
let's start at this okay now what can
you do with this thing I want to show
that this is positive okay so I want to
get some squares involved because
squares number one are already in fear
and number two I know this guy is
positive so how can I get some squares
out of this what way can I arrange it to
show that they're Swift well and you
probably the easiest way to factorize
this is a what's it called
okay when you have four terms often the
best way is to pair them up okay so
which what we prepared yeah I think I
think the x squared and the X cube may
have a common factor of X square right
so if I take in let me maybe I straight
on expand this side so that I don't get
my negative speeds done okay
I'll pair up is x squared Y with the X
cubed
likewise I'll pair up the Y cube with
the X Y squared
okay
so now my factorization through the
obvious I should say take out the X
squid then right take out the Y squared
here now what am I got okay
I've almost got a common factor again
right what do I have to do in order to
make a color yeah this is negative I
want to turn that around okay so if I
have this still at the front and turn
that to a minus sign okay now I've got a
difference of squares happening okay hmm
now this is better it's it's factorized
whereas this was just a mess okay but it
still won't do I don't know it like the
difference of squares can still be
negative right if one square is if the
square small of this one and this one
well I know that they're not equal to
each other but I don't know which is
bigger right they hadn't said anything
which has begun okay so this isn't
enough what else could I do okay so now
you can see where it's going right now
they've got to lots of X minus y this
I've got X plus y at the front and then
I've got X minus y all square there
there we go okay now at this point
usually I'm going to this is sort of
like my last line of real work okay I
can conclude in a second usually at this
point I have to invoke my conditions
okay and I'm gonna write something
really nice and succinct here okay
but because we're just starting out I
want to make sure you guys understand
why I'm putting these conditions here
I'm gonna write this in longhand so
probably um you won't need to write this
out in this much detail okay but I want
you to understand why it's there okay
I've got a product here right and I want
it to be positive
that's the point of me doing all this
factorizing
so if I want to product to be positive
I've got two alternatives it's just two
things right I can either prove that
both of them are negative right because
negative times negative is positive or I
can prove that both of them are positive
and then I'm fine okay so in this case
which is it if I'm positive right so I
got two and I should deal with it
separately so X plus y right it's
greater than zero how do I know because
each of them individually is positive so
when you take the sum that you find now
X minus y careful
just now I rubbed it off already but I
said if you swear something oh it could
it could be you know you've got a
boundary here right but this won't be
useful right if I take something which
must be positive and something which is
sometimes positive but sometimes it's
zero okay I'm not guaranteed that the
product will be positive so how do I get
rid of this battery yeah that's right
the only way it would be equal to the
boundary is if X 4 equal to Y but it's
not right does that make sense
so therefore yeah now getting there
right so this depends on these two but
this in turn this one depends on this is
that make sense
this one depends on yes so you can sort
of see how why am i saying that this why
am I going to say this product is
positive because of these but why these
true because of my initial what was
given to me that make sense so what are
you actually usually fine to write
really is this part okay you'll get your
foundation really okay so what I've
announced to is usually you're just
going to quote what conditions they give
you okay this kind of step here is sort
of unnecessary okay however when I'm
doing equality proofs I write them just
so I know like why did I invent these
because these are the important things
and I recommend especially like we just
this outright that you put in this step
okay I think it's really helpful to and
clarify your understanding and for a
marketing point of view so that I know
then you know what you're doing okay
anyone can just copy out the conditions
from the from the question without
understanding why okay but this is it
could be real it could be Vince just
that's what the questions if they're not
all positive then I might not be able to
say this because if one of them was a
big negative number then one was
positive then this will not be true and
so even though this will be positive
I don't know this terminal so I want the
inequality won't be true the minute all
right now I'm always there
remember I told you this was basically
the last night of working so having
justify that this is positive the
Equality can turn into bless you know it
can turn into an inequality see that
okay so I'm going from this line to this
line and cuz that's a big step that's
what all of this explanation is about
okay you can't just stop there this is
like the crucial explaining part okay
sure I could say since this thing which
I started with okay since that thing is
positive that's positive now I just put
this guy over
and that's how you sit up and in a holy
proof okay so I think the two things I
would read to your attention up number
one where do you stop you have to start
with the expression and not say that an
inequality applies to it
I can't assume it's greater than zero
because that's where I'm going to end
okay so number one your starting point
get it right sometimes it's obvious
right sometimes as you've seen these
letter questions it's not something she
could be something for now but to when
you're doing this crucial step from the
inequality because sorry the Equality
because it's just factorizing to an
inequality you must justify okay this is
really really crucial and then you just
tidy up okay any questions yeah I
haven't worked backwards I just worked
for words I've looked at this expression
right and from here all the way up to
here all I've done has just been
rewriting it in a more useful for okay a
form that I can say ah now that I'm here
I know that that's positive I can use
some logic based on my initial
conditions to say this must be positive
okay
so after I do what my super fly now I
can bring it in equality in because of
all of my reasoning so what would be
different is to start here say yeah it's
greater than zero and then do blah blah
blah
move things around and you would end
here sorry you did here but of course
you can't hear because that's kind of
where you started right so that's that's
the difference and even though it's a
simple difference people keep making
they're all the web to you
okay yes good question so the question
is will I am i changing the question
like by changing what I've required to
prove by starting to work with this okay
and you do have to be careful it's a
good question ask the reason why this is
equivalent to what I am going to try to
prove right it's because did you notice
this is what I was working with which is
here now what's the difference it's a
lotta rhetorical question what's the
difference with what I've been working
with and what I was trying to prove what
is the difference the difference between
them is an addition subtraction
difference okay now addition subtraction
multiplication division we're talking
about this there okay if you know what
you're doing okay
squaring on the other hand or moving
things sort of like yeah that's right
you got me if I'm multiplying by things
that I know properties about then it's
okay right but can you see I haven't
actually moved anything
I don't looks like I've moved this
across right we're t2 here then actually
this expression here I can treat it
independently from this equation okay
so it's not like I've moved it across
and then I started doing things to do
operations to both sides
because this doesn't have a both sides
okay I'm just simplifying and rewriting
the same thing over and over
all right